hello everyone and welcome to the recap
show of the san luis rabbit and blitz my
name is tati varahamian and i'm going to
take you to the highlights of day one of
blitz
so today there were 45 blitz games that
were played which is an overwhelming
amount of games so there is no way i can
go through
all the key moments or to all the
highlights so
what i've chosen to do is to go through
the highlights of the
top three players the players who are
currently in top three so
there's gonna be a bit of a spoiler but
not too much surprise
considering how the tournament ended
yesterday
where wesley saw was in first place and
magnus carlson in second and there was
uh
some fight for third place between nepo
and hikaru and alexander griezchuk
because they were all very close
uh so there's been some changes uh right
now um
magnus carlson lee prague wesley saw and
um so it's magnus carlsen wesley so and
in third place we have
yeah nippon nichi so you guys can tell
me in the comments if this is not how
you wanted to do it
but this is what i've chosen to do today
so we have a lot of games to go through
so let's get started
so in the very first round we already
have a very juicy matchup between magnus
carlsen in hikaru nakamura
and i already talked about their great
rivalry over the summer
so let's jump to move 21.
so this was a really nice game by magnus
carlson and i think you're just going to
be in
awe by his play so i'm actually going to
go to most of his games because he had
eight decisive results
and it was like a roller coaster of
emotions today
so there's a lot to get through and um
a lot of fun moments so he goes e5 great
move
not surprisingly
so h4 pushing the pawn
and what i want to show you is this
endgame moment where he
allows this double pawns and just check
out what he does after which is so
amazing to me
putting the pawn on f5 this dominant
bishop the king runs 3-4
not much for hikar to do unfortunately
and uh the part that i want to show you
is here
takes on g7 and transposes into a
winning rook and game and you could see
car was very unhappy shaking his head
it's not a secret that he does show a
lot of emotions during the game which is
especially nice during this kind of a
tournament where you have a
shot of his face so you can actually see
every emotion that he goes through
so pushing the pawns of course cannot
trade rooks and just goes after every
pawn
so really nice way for the world
champion to start his day
i would have win over hikara nakamura so
let's jump to his second
game where he plays against jeffrey
zhang
the young american grandmaster so we
will jump
through the end where things get decided
so in this position excuse me
g4 is played and now we're going to see
that there's a
mating net because after this move g5
and a really nice
a really nice mating idea because the
rook went
to h3 and now rook cc-8 and
impossible to stop the mate so really
unfortunate for a while the game was
pretty close pretty equal
and but there are always some uh
checkmating ideas and of course the
world champion is not the one to ignore
them and
unfortunately this caused the young
cause cost the youngster the game
so the next game uh magnus carlsen
actually lost his game
against uh pantala hare krishna so let's
jump to move 15.
and we'll take a look at um hare
krishna's technique
so it's up to pawns but opposite color
bishops
never easy um there are always some
tricks in a position when we have
opposite color bishops
so it takes a pawn it's a nice three
pawns
and i really like this this final move
that i'm about to show you
chasing the bishop away and now f7 is
coming uh
so nice game by fentalahari krishna
defeating the world champion with the
white pieces
so you know magnus carlsen after losing
a game is a very dangerous opponent he's
a dangerous opponent every
every round obviously but after he loses
he really wants uh to get back
so his next round opponent
did not fare too well against him okay
so the next game we're going to take a
look at
is round four against levon aronian and
this game was absolutely crazy again
i cannot do it justice in this kind of a
video you would have to take a look at
it yourself
i would suggest you do this and i
suggest you take a closer look at every
single game i go over
and this was a very high quality game
even with all the mistakes
obviously it's a blitz game so magnus
carlson is playing
amazingly here it goes e5 so here it's
correct for him to go d6
but he goes moves the rook away which is
natural because the
rook was looking sketchy there and now
we get this
insane position and it's going to get
even more insane as we're going to see
how these pawns are just starting to
roll down the board
so he did steal a pawn on a7 i'm going a
little bit fast because
we're about to reach a crazy position so
we reach this position
uh there's an extra bishop on the board
but there is
a lot of pawns rolling down and uh
such a scary position to play with no
time on your uh clock
so h3 because the d6 punt is his he
doesn't want the spawn moving pawns
moving and of course
his rook cannot leave
there's some background issues runs back
i don't even know whose side i would
rather be on so apparently
in this position rook g8 is a very great
move which actually makes sense because
i just want to defend this uh pawn
this rook is kind of out of play and
just start rolling this
start pushing this pawn and three pounds
on the third ring
not going to be pleasant so instead he
checks
and again he has very little time on the
clock and f2 is of course a blunder
because
now all the pawns hang and he doesn't
have time to play e2 with a tempo
uh i mean something like this happened
in a few moves because check and then
we're just going to grab this pawn
so instead he takes so had he gone e2
rook c1 let me go back
so had he done something like this we
would take here
and it would be very similar to what we
have in the end game so this would be i
mean the game
so these are very similar lines
and now the pawn just runs
takes but now there is no stopping the
pawn and the white king is shouldering
the black king
unfortunately this checks don't help as
he just runs away
i'm not sure why he went there and not
here i don't think it makes a
difference i mean you're lying a few
more checks but
can't just run away and the game is just
over
it's a really nice me win by magnus
carlsen who now
has three out of four and he did have
the best uh result of the day which
we can conclude just based on the fact
that he live throughout his opponent
his arrival rather okay so let's take a
look at the next game
where he is playing yandi pomneichim and
we are going
to jump to move 49 so he did lose this
game
so i did tell you at all decisive games
except
for the last round where uh he drew
wesley some so every game we see is
going to be decisive
so i just want to show you the final of
the position where roxy4 unfortunately
loses to
a skewer and i will also go back and
show you the opening maybe you can try
taking a
guess uh something he promised that
he will also play tomorrow because he
know what that is he doesn't feel like
it's realistic for him to catch the
leaders
so he played 1v3 so hopefully we'll see
more of this tomorrow because it's
definitely going to be
entertaining all right so
um next game was magnus versus chris
chook um
so this was a demolition um
did not fare it too well so he did bit
magnus yesterday but today
it did not go uh too well so if we take
a look at this position
immediately this stands out as well as
this and the reason i'm showing you this
game is because he
does a rook lift and rook lifts are my
favorite idea in chess
and swings the rook over so now the rook
on b1
became an attacking piece so now it's
going to be really hard to defend
that king on h8 so another piece joins
the attack
and
it's becoming very difficult to defend
everyone and particularly this bishop on
e6
to be more specific because the queen
moves we just take the bishop
king on e1 is perfectly safe black just
finished development
so things did not go well for the
russian grand master
so the next game is going to be one of
the wildest games of the tournament
and i suggest you guys go and check out
magnus's reaction
after this game was over you can check
it out on san luis's twitter account
it's endless just club's twitter account
uh he was absolutely disgusted he was
just like like
as possible like um
and uh fearuja was kind of laughing
after the game like it's kind of more
more like uh when you can't believe it
happened kind of laugh
because uh this game was another
rollercoaster
and i know i've said this a lot about a
lot of games but a lot of the games have
been a rollercoaster
all right so let's start in this
position so rook 1 c4 is played
magnus misses bishop eight
and now young firoza wins a queen
but the position is locked so he
sacrifices a bishop
king goes back a very subtle threat of
mating one
attacking the bishop and rook f7
so the correct way of winning was take
take and take on h3 and taking on h3 is
a move that furuta said that he
forgot about uh but this is completely
winning and as i mentioned yesterday if
you checked out that
video two pawns on the sixth rank um are
unstoppable by the rook
so for example if you take this i can
already do this
and we're coining and if you play king
g7
e6 and the problem is for example if i
play d7 here then you have this nice
move of
king f6 and now the pawns are stopped
but i do play e7 with a tempo if
someone was attempt was not a tempo you
would be able to play king f7 and stop
the pawns again
but because a7 is a tempo
this is not working out really well
uh so really disappointing result for um
hiroshi of course you know beating the
world champion is not an
opportunity to get every game so to let
this go
he was he was not i mean after the game
he was just like
how did this happen but yeah even um
post-game interview he said that he had
so many good positions today just i
didn't understand how he kept messing
them up
and let's take a look at our final game
by magnus carlson against lanier
dominguez
and this game there was a huge huge
um plunder
i will just show you that moment magnus
plays rookie two and uh
dominguez of course has rook f8 and
because of back rank
and actually it's funny that the rook is
placed specifically on e2 so you don't
have bishop d3 covering the back rank so
this would just win a piece but this was
missed
um so i will take you to the key
position because a lot happens and
uh i don't want to go through every
single move uh so i will take it to this
position so opposite color bishops and i
think it's easy to become
become complacent in this kind of
positions because you think you build a
fortress and
the game is over like it's a draw like
everything is good and
one mistake and the game is over and
especially against someone like magnus
who will
play until the very very end so here
king a4
and dominguez plays his harmless looking
move king g7
he should have played bishop d2 and i
will show you why
and after a3 the bishop has to stay on
the diagonal
and now there's just no way to defend
two pawns
so bishop d2 had to be played just so a
move like a3 could be met with bishop c1
and the king cannot really leave the
bishop i mean i'm sorry the king cannot
live the palm so we can just wait with
the king
and this is a very easy draw
because the bishop can just stay on b4
and go to e1 when necessary and just
stay on the diagonal to defend the pun
so very unfortunate loss by dominguez
but you know it is a blitz game and
with no time on the clock i feel like
this kind of end games are very very
easy to use
all right so that's uh that was magnus's
day our tall roller coaster but you know
if
uh magnus's worst day is or a bad day as
maybe he thought
uh because he was quite unhappy about
few of his games is six and a half out
of nine then um
so better than anyone else's then better
than any of my
good chess days all right so let's
move on to wesley so so my sister
actually started his game with a loss
against the young american grandmaster
jeffrey zhang
and i feel like this was actually very
instructive in game
and i really like how jeffrey played
this
so rook d5 was played which is a
excellent move because
if the king attacks your pawn you can
defend it from this right now you're
getting ready to push your pawn so the
rule goes there
defending and here he actually makes a
mistake
he should have just kept pushing his
pawn i believe
ah sorry so actually this position was
the mistake you should have played
rookie five attacking this pawn
uh instead he plays rook d2 king f1
and here there's this amazing resource
which um
uh impossible to find is to play rook f4
with the idea of king f1 so we cannot
push this pawn because this pawn will be
lost
and otherwise
let me go back to the position otherwise
um
if you move your key well you cannot
move your king because i have e3
but let's say i make some kind of a move
and now i can get one
and
the pawn is lost so for example here
and it's going to be queen versus queen
the white wolf queen and black wolf
queen and the game will end in a draw
so this was an amazing resource i think
very very hard to find
uh we're going to see this in some kind
of an endgame book at some point
instead king of three split which is i
think it's a more natural movie it's a
temple move
you defend your pawn you attack the
rogue you have no time on your clock
so now he plays this very correctly
and kind of a lucina position even
though the rook is
not on the right
uh the the rook is not on the
right rank usually it's on the fourth
rank but here um
rook v2 doesn't quite work out because
the pawn
falls so instead rook d2 is played
and rook b3 i really like because you
don't want to queen and lose your rook
and then you have to start winning all
over again
and you're just getting a full queen so
really nice game by jeffrey junk
delivering wesley so
uh his first loss of the day in the very
first round
so was this recovered very quickly in
his second game by defeating
pentala harikrishnan uh this was a
really nice game
by wesley he just
if you can guess the opening was another
karo khan which means seems to be
the theme of the tournament
so f5 was played e6 and just destroying
this king
trying to trap the bishop with h5
and h6 and just completely destroying
the king side
so we're taking so he had a great move
of playing bishop h5
so the knight would fall with a check
instead he takes
and in this position the computer just
gives
zeros which is kind of difficult to
figure out
after rook uh cf8 it says the position
is equal
which is if you look at this position
it's anything but equal or anything but
zeros but
um again this is something that's hard
for me to explain in this kind of a
video and like i would have to spend
some time trying to understand this
myself
i i guess that the whole idea is uh
instead of rook gf8 was played but i
think the idea is to keep this rook here
and of course this rule cannot leave
because of a checkmate threat and of
course we cannot take
okay but instead this was played and
okay some trades happened
and just grabs the piece so nice
recovery
so the next game was aetra and uh the
final decisive
game by wesley saw was in round four
against
nippon nichi this was a really nice game
and i think
he showed really nice technique and
[Music]
he's very good at this kind of position
i feel like
a technical position where he needs to
convert
okay so let's get started from here so
rook d1 is played so he gets a great
position out of the opening
it's a grunfeld and the bishop is not
where it belongs it's on the wrong
diagonal in some way
in some way it's in a good diagonal but
obviously white is doing really well
because here you're starting to figure
out there are no moves
so he wins a queen and now let's check
out his technique
exchanging the pair a4
and now we'll start harassing on the
king side
so a5
okay losing the pawn was of course
not ideal but i really like this part
the queen e3 is of course trading down
uh to your king and pawn end game does
not work out because
uh you're not even close to being on
time
i'm now pinning the rook so there's you
can again you cannot take with the
bishop i will take the rook
so let's check out how this game ends um
the king goes to g5 so really nice looks
like uh cannot go
to this side because the pawn is
queening so it was just too much
material and
wesley went on to draw the rest of his
game so he fell
a half a point behind magnus carlson so
there was
some kind of a battle for third place
between as i mentioned nepo and nakamura
and grizzchuk
a lot of drama and yesterday grishchick
was joking that his goal for the
tournament was to finish
ninth and he was like oh nothing nothing
has changed
uh he does what he said after um
after he finished uh in top three
and today uh nepa was jerky saying the
same thing like my goal is also
not to finish uh um not to finish last
which was christian's point you know
it's always unpleasant to finish last
all right so let's check out um nepal's
tournament
so we already saw a couple of his games
against uh so and against magnus
so uh let's check out his first game it
was um
actually his first game excuse me was a
drag against alexander grieschuk so
let's check out his second game against
um
alireza furuja and this is um one of the
games that i
razer won in this tournament and this
was a just a crazy wild game
and what i want to show you is
this opposite color bishop position
because oftentimes opposite colored
bishop positions are just assumed to be
drawn but when there's a lot of material
on the board opposite-colored bishops
are very dangerous
and we're going to see how this kink is
going to get checkmated actually
spoiler alert
so check
cannot take
and made is coming
and the final game we're going to check
out by nepal is going to be his last
round game against hikaru nakamura this
game was full of emotion again there's a
clip on the san luis obispo
twitter channel which you should check
out the car was
very not pleased with himself throughout
the game i think some of the decisions
he was just visibly like what am i doing
here
so he takes on his uh after 27 he takes
on e6 and
a decision that he lives to regret is
the rule goes to d1
trying again opposite color bishops but
a lot of pieces on the board so the
position is quite dangerous
rook f8 and
the rook f8 was a threat
and uh a bit of a repetition of
opposition
very disappointing move to play i mean
it's already hard to suggest a good move
rook g7 is made um so
in this position he moved the rook away
from g6 so the king would have a g6
square
and then and this is some kind of a
glitch that happens to chess players
sometimes
you kind of forget why you made a move
so it goes back and he gets checkmated
but honestly it's really hard to suggest
a good move because if you do something
like this
i mean okay you're just losing material
so this is not much consolation
uh yeah so um pretty a pretty
heartbreaking way to lose a game anyways
um it's always unpleasant to lose the
last round games regardless of what
happens and how the tournament is it's
just kind of lose a bad taste in your
mouth but
um there's another day tomorrow with
nine runs so if he has a good day
tomorrow there can be a big turnaround
and uh finally i wanted to show you two
more games by already russia because i
know he's a big fan favorite
and his style of play is very exciting
which i'm a big fan
of because i like attacking chess i like
aggressive chess
and he's a very exciting player and he
has this energy of youth
so let's check out his last round game
against bantala hare krishna
so we see the king made his way to 83
and we're going to check out and see how
the king got there
so the king starts on c7 so let's take a
look at
the journey of this king
uh so he is down a piece but there is a
pawn on f7
and there's a king on v6 now there's a
king on b5
so check
bring the summon um and now
there's just no good move this gets made
it and he played this and now he's
losing his
queen and i losing his queen is also
going to lose his knight and the game
especially because there's uh the fact
that there is a pawn on f7 is going to
make things even quicker so really nice
victory by
the youngest player in the tournament
the 17 year old alright of perugia
and finally the last game i want to show
you is uh between
hikaru nakamura and other researchers so
affirmative was on the losing side of
this game but
i know also hikaru is a big fan favorite
so this was the clash that everyone was
looking forward to
uh so let's take a look at the final or
the key moments and the final moments of
this game
so knight g4 is play play trying to
exploit the dark square bishops as we do
see the queen perfectly placed
so check and now this king is going for
a walk
and i wanted to show this game because
of where the king ends up
so we've seen several adventurous kings
so we see the king to acquire the
journey ends up on d6 on rook d5
really nice way of ending the game and
winning the queen
so it looks like this is going to be a
two horse race between
magnus carlsen and wesley so so magnet
magnus carlson leads
wesley so by half a point and wesley so
it's three points ahead of
um yanni pomichi so unless there is
uh you know some kind of a big result or
one person
has a really bad day or another person
has a phenomenal day scoring like eight
or seven and a half
it looks like it is going to be between
magnus and wesley so
so as usual i encourage you to check out
these games on your own you can check
them out on usgs champs
and make sure you're tuning in tomorrow
for the final day of the saint louis
rapid and blitz
thank you guys for checking this out and
see you tomorrow